so highway patrol and local police well
they've obviously got their hands full
responding to
all of these deadly crashes we're joined
now by trooper travis macker from the
nevada highway patrol good morning
troopers mack and thank you for joining
us
good morning nate so what can we do to
stop
people from wrong way driving i'm
guessing impairment has a lot to do with
those
yes uh as you well know especially in
our overnight hours here in las vegas we
are a destination city
with 24 hour a day seven day a week
access to alcohol and now marijuana
and unfortunately one of those side
effects is people dr making the poor
selfish decision to drive impaired and
that often leads to someone
getting on our highways going the wrong
direction counterflow to traffic
and anytime we investigate a collision
involving a runway driver
it's usually pretty grim now one of the
things we're also talking about
unfortunately over the weekend is a
string of fatal
auto pedestrian crashes and obviously
impairment could be a factor there
but troopers maka pedestrians can also
do a lot to make themselves
safe when they are walking the streets
especially when you're talking about the
highways nate there is absolutely
no reason for anyone to be walking along
our highways it is no place for a
pedestrian to be
even if somebody is experiencing car
trouble don't
start walking along the highway stay
with your vehicles try to stay off into
the shoulder as far as you can
do everything you can to stay as far
away from the actual
travel lanes as possible like i said
earlier
there's absolutely that's no place for a
pedestrian to be
especially at highway speeds it's a very
dangerous situation
one last question for you troopers maka
we know that driving impaired is a thing
that will probably never go away but
what can we do to stop people we know
maybe we're at an event do we just say
hey take their keys do we
tell them to call a ride share what do
we do
a combination of those nate both of
those are great ideas
if you have somebody you're with you're
able to get the keys from that is
fantastic
what i often recommend to those people
is if you know you're going to a venue
and you know you're going to
have alcohol or something else that may
impair your ability to operate a motor
vehicle
plan ahead and take an uber ride share
lift or some other public transportation
to that venue
and then when it comes time to leaving
that venue you're not leaving that
critical
decision up to somebody who's already
impaired you've already decided that
outcome way earlier troopers macca thank
you so much for taking the time to be
with us and thank you to all the men and
women of the nhp that do
hard work every single day to keep us
safe on the roads we'll let you get back
to it
yes sir